[Música]
la conciencia negra y en más de 110
ciudades de brasil
este es el barrio de madureira un barrio
popular de río de janeiro aquí como en
otras ciudades el lema es también para
cocinar o fuera con sónar porque se han
juntado los movimientos de izquierda que
desde el mes de mayo piden el
impeachment del actual presidente de
brasil
[Música]
que fuera evolucionado porque es racista
machista el gmt fóbico genocida
y más de 600 mil muertos en brasil
desempleo mata a los pobres a los
indígenas destruye la naturaleza
está matando al pueblo de hambre
[Música]
él está destruyendo las instituciones
democráticas está destruyendo a nuestras
poblaciones originarias entonces es
sumamente importante la unificación de
este movimiento para que ese poder para
éste fuera bolsonaro porque la economía
del país está cada vez peor que sufre
más son los trabajadores los negros y
los pueblos originales y pueblos
originarios
[Música]
las reivindicaciones del movimiento
negro racial tiene casi 14 millones de
desempleados el 33% son negros y
mestizos frente a un 10 por ciento de
blancos además del hambre aumentó
durante el gobierno con sonar un 27% y
de nuevo la población negra es la más
afectada